- hey papa here it's Papa John and
you're listening to the h3 podcast go
Ethan go ela well thank you papa John I
appreciate the intro how nice now Papa
John personally endorsing this the H
flute podcast the greatest show
undisputed undisputed night on the
street it's just it's a household name
people say the greatest show a street
podcast a household name a today's
episode is sponsored by quip who we know
and love peopIe was docketed to be on
our show today but unfortunately he
cancelled brutally I thought
thoughtlessly on the last minute we had
him all ready to go and he said
something came up so very rude it was
very frankly was offended but that's not
here no there I'm trying to keep the
show wholesome and light today despite
the fact that there is a a entire
country of Italy is shut down
everybody is instructed to stay in their
house in Italy and there is a sociopath
verse a literally senile man running for
president calling Bernie a sociopath not
burning no I mean look we've got the
lawn we've got a line dog-faced
pony-soldiers play live in that trap
again you're lying dog freeze pony shows
me did I play that on the podcast before
yeah so we've got so it looks like Joe's
gonna win but I'm gonna keep it cool I'm
keeping it light and warm
we're in 3d I'm not I'm not I'm just
keeping it cool despite all this
happening in the world and if you're in
Italy don't go outside no problem at all
you're not allowed to leave your house
if you're in Italy not a issue right Zak
yeah show me your bag pack yeah Zak's
cruises around with the bag
yeah but don't say the word don't say
the word okay so I got I got wipes yeah
are those disinfect it's so hard to get
right now is that God you get those
Ralphs they just had him around yeah I
guess they just need to live with the
hug man like he's bought a can for a
thousand bucks
I was looking Amazon everything is out
of stock that's the risk though you have
to go into a Ralph's to get it that's
how you get sick and then I got it I got
gloves to show me are those disposable
oh yeah they are so you bought like a
bag of a thousand of them or something
well I I wash my card
so like they're like car washing books
so do you throw them out left to use
them yeah and so when do you put those
on like uh when I go to the gas station
anytime I have to like touch it so if
you've got if you're pumping gas put on
the gloves you finished the job you
throw the gloves out yeah and then like
you use your like pointer finger to just
get the glove off and then goes right in
the trash can I'm not gonna lie I've
thought about that putting gloves
because I I there's nothing worse than
touching a gas nozzle dude is nothing
worse once you go into this ahold germ
alert mode it's like you can't avoid it
it's you gonna touch something I don't
know apparently Zach disagrees well my
hands are also dry as [ __ ] because I've
been watching five minutes I know it's
the worst man but no we're not taught
we're not getting stuck in the hole but
zach is carrying around a bag of
disinfectant I am Zach how was your hair
in the last episode you soaked your hair
in Manning's correct tell me about the
aftermath
well I left and the car ride home was
pretty gnarly I had to drive with the
windows down got home it took me like
three shampoos to get it the all of it
out like the smell and all wise mmm but
I think the dish soap soap kind of
messed it up Oh messed it up yeah
because I think it just kind of stripped
my hair and made it super dry it was
soft but I mean it's super it's so
strong yeah there's so so ultimately any
benefit you reaped from soaking hair and
mayonnaise was negated by washing your
hair with dish soap correct but the
experience was amazing I mean it's a
gentle hand I really loved I was
watching it back over the weekend and I
was I was laughing a lot it was so it
was a great mom I was watching him on TV
when the episode came before the whole
good and I was like oh my god we know
this guy I'm in love with big Edie he
felt good on this he's promising one of
the best seasons of 90 days yeah I think
we have the making of an absolute
reality TV superstar I love they get and
I love that we're in touch with them you
know later in the episode today we will
be interviewing the Philly attack right
did I was like such an old Brit I'm
around a soft brain a smooth brain
sometimes my brain is smooth and
sometimes it's hard okay boomer don't
okay boomer myself okay the the Philly
offensive will be joining us for an
interview after the break which I'm very
excited about he's the man the myth the
legend behind roll patrol and stake is
for taxpayers love him Oh Zach speaking
of May own your hair I saw this on the
subreddit and I wanted to get your take
on it I thought it was really funny hair
either
yeah what I would like for you to do is
put on those gloves okay this is not the
okay here we go yeah and we're gonna get
to strip my hair ah the man your hair
either you didn't want to get it I've
there for you to do it and put on those
gloves and start massaging mayonnaise in
his head don't worry about making a mess
that's totally fine Wow I do not know
it's pretty funny fantastic yeah
somebody went back in time to Zach when
he had the when the mayo meme first was
born and he said I don't want to get
mayo my hair and now here he is
pretty good right so there you go thanks
that just goes to show you how things
can change how quickly things can Jane
very true
Trisha is coming on this Friday if you
have a less or I guess hurt though it's
closed right we said the cutoff was last
Sunday so you snooze you lose and I got
to tell you we got a lot of applications
so tight
how many applications it wouldn't be an
exaggeration to say hundreds right guys
I mean and what's our short stack I
think we've got what maybe 20 25 of like
whoa like real real solid ones do you
think that there's anyone in there that
you could potentially actually fall in
love with there's some zingers there's
some zingers
maybe blind Dan you it sounds like you
wouldn't [ __ ] any of them uh well most
of them are males oh so there are some
females I'd all but just a few are
female yeah I mean she said that she's
not into women at least strong right she
said she's not into straight women which
it's really hard to keep track with her
yeah so if you have a last-minute
application go ahead and send it to
podcast a shoe a shoe brush come we will
consider it if it's fantastic but what I
wanted to do just to tempt you all and
get hyped up for this Friday when Trisha
will be joining us to make defend the
herd is to enjoy video from her age she
made a ASMR video it's called no talky
Trish ASMR and I wanted to enjoy see
this this could all be yours
so this is awful
I hate so this I mean why would you like
love it I mean I I doesn't bother me but
I don't get love hate you're the
producer of the show then you can't
think
yeah did Dan bounce he's done skis dad
I'm holding the headphones near my head
so this is like ruining the dish for me
that does look good
here's the thing this could all be yours
if you enter at podcast at a stress
reduction calm you could be sitting
beside her right now she's eating well
let me just describe to our audio
listeners there's a giant bowl of tea
what kind of pasta would you call that
Shell's
like a macaroni it's a shell macaroni a
super cheesy and she's eating it with a
giant wooden spoon like a serving scale
I mean love it not even well I'm lucky I
just so this is called super cheesy mac
and cheese big bites big bite
no talking ASMR no I said now what's the
what's the purpose do you think the
purpose of this is to jerk off to sleep
to relax
what well this is the same market as
some of the other ASMR channel I think
it's person and she's combining milk
bangs with the bar right nobody so it's
for people who like to watch her eat
plus there's some more sounds mmm
that seems very niche yeah but it has
50,000 views and a lot of life
but let's see what other kind of videos
she has on no no talkie trick she really
isn't you guys have to you guys have to
give it up that she is a [ __ ] natural
born hustler did she like Oprah sure
she's been on every single possible show
dude she is a natural
born hustler this is let me see I think
this is our most popular video here
what's the most recent upload one one
way so it was that after she announced
that she this crunchy says a some our
head of crunchy lettuce this is just her
eating a head of lettuce all right let's
see where this goes
taking lettuce out of a bag it's just a
head of lettuce you know like a ball why
would anybody want want to do that
just a big head of lettuce and she's
just going in for a bite here we go get
ready
she's taking her time Ian you listen
ASMR does this do anything for you I
don't listen anymore
me you yes all right I tried it a little
bit but it didn't really help I feel
like you're revising history I think
Ian's it really helped me fall asleep I
would be too focused okay dude this is
Corey this is gross though I don't like
this this doesn't help this wouldn't
help you policy no after your easy bro
she's just straight up destroying she's
just like I mean she's a fart and I
don't mean I mean she literally just a
farm animal I don't mean that like as it
her looks I mean I just never seen an
animal other than a farm animal hit a
head of lettuce like that right either
I mean I'm blown away about what I'm
saying right
I've never seen some like this you can't
taking huge bites out of a full head of
lettuce and gives me anxiety I don't
know I just never seen anything like and
that's 110,000 like so maybe the comics
mylord peel off the first layer at least
that's what's on your mind damn you
should probably watch that first just
why are you guys she's that's hardly the
issue here
well lettuce is famously what people get
I'm wash lettuce is what people get
e.coli from right well cool by the way
probably should have washed
I mean well if I'm guessing she probably
washed she did wash it and put it in the
back because she wanted to look like she
just took it out of the bag forever
perhaps because that's the whole vibe
awesome for her own sake let me give her
the benefit of the doubt here but
everybody's just talking about ecoli and
watch but well okay
she is an innovator my dudes that's our
most popular one edible dish sponge what
like I like this so this one's called
edible dish sponge deodorant stick yeah
then diesel keep yeah that's what I'm
thinking wait so it's food made in the
shape of a spine I think it's just a
cake that looks like a sponge it says
big yeah I don't know why would you make
an edible sponge out of a cake why why
why would you do this she's trying stuff
but why would you make a sponge it says
edible dish sponge and deodorant sticks
[Laughter]
and easels into this he might be the
only one who's really into this is VIN
whoa
it's Vin Diesel the action star is
really a fan of Tricia
oh my god the vin diesel do you have
anything to say I just googled a edible
dish sponge and don't tell me that's a
genre it seems to be a thing this world
why do people want to eat the bun jizz
like here this one looks crazy oh here's
another ASMR channel oh 1.5 million
it's got like Julian in it says ASMR
edible cake dish sponge eating show
Frank most satisfying than all the
downwards and then it has like Korean
and then it says Moo ping oh that looks
like a real sponge
Tricia's didn't this looks like she just
strip eating a sponge that's pretty
crazy it's just preview what is this hey
I need a preview Oh No why she's got
hold on what the and we just stumble
into it so she's got a thing of dish
soap that look has it filled with
something that looks like she'll dress
just like sugar water yeah with food
colors this is a whole fetish and so
she's a really cute young girl who's
thin and slender and fit and she's just
eating sponges I guess some people have
a fantasy of eating sponges but this has
1.5 million to 1.6 million views
there's no way let me read comments mmm
I mean people are maiming on but but
clearly people are maybe it's just
shocking and people click it like what
well when I is if you just do a Google
search for edible dish sponge like the
the image results there's like tons of
thumbnails from videos like it seems
like it was a trend or something I have
to give it to her though these look
fantastically real they do I mean those
are what dude this is your life imagine
your mom sees this like how do you
explain this to your mom she goes crazy
how many views is that 1.6 million
you show her the reference tab yeah it's
not enough oh I guess you're right
that's happened to us your dad goes why
is Ethan showing close ups of his dick
on screen that's probably worse than
eating sponges yeah for some reason I
find this harder to explain yeah cuz you
don't get it
what would your dad think I was eating
sponges like this are you you not me
doesn't care if you were eating sponges
I [ __ ] it's easier and a way to explain
cuz it's like look at this illusion like
she baked or whatever I don't know how
it's made like it's impressive it's kind
of impressive it's very impressive I
don't know how to make this okay you
like my mom would be like wow how did
you bake it you know what can I get you
to make a video like this cuz I'm cuz
like oh like if we hire a baker I feel
like we could generate like a whole
nother revenue stream with you doing
videos like this yes mr alright yeah a
Samara and just get someone to bring us
some fixed why did you sit there maybe
like you know die eating and I hate
eating sounds as everyone knows I hate
our eating's and I get you two in a
white shirt without a bra huh
a white shirt no bra okay well I'm
trying to entice our viewers okay to
watch the sponge eating because they are
all wearing like like you know
what stuff waters venting so think about
this Vin Diesel time today all right
well then Diesel's a fan of edible cake
dish what what look at the thumbnail
these boomers what is happening on
YouTube look at these people like people
will do anything to make money what is
this
can you see this thumbnail yep we can
see pretty well Oh
scroll down just a hair perfect burp
this thumbnail what that look how do you
not click that here she's eating a shoe
oh cool you see it's like a king no it's
cool I agree what's the word you know
it's a piece of art in the baking words
probably I don't know I agree I'm just I
just impressive the whole thing is crazy
dude the a Samar the eating the sponge
is just so crazy I wonder if she bakes
it do you think she just hired like
she's eating a cold and MasterChef where
do you find someone to make this well
with that kind of views she probably has
39 million a crew of chefs alright let's
watch I'm gonna click that one now I
didn't even plan to watch this stuff by
the way
she's like Willy Wonka yeah you know
that scene where he like I love that
scene he was the first ace of our food
fetish sure that scene Willy Wonka where
he takes a sip from the teacup and then
eats it yeah I love that so he's the man
she's eating a calm does she just puke I
mean how do you work off calories like
that what has been diesel think about
this videogame predict guy yeah I
thought that's true she is pretty Vin
Diesel anything else yeah he's talking
all right
he doesn't have met Vin Diesel only says
he doesn't have a large vocabulary yeah
I know I I know I I get you Vin Diesel
I'm gonna have to work on educating him
some more it's a more vocabulary I lost
my place where well what are we doing
again I don't know we have a document oh
yeah we were watching Trish's the winner
I'm happy to announce the winner of the
Tricia Bachelorette season will be what
we will be sending both of you all on a
beautiful cruise we looked up cruises as
you know we found a beautiful 20 day
cruise that stops out on China beautiful
China see the walls the wonders of the
ancient civilization
China China as Trump likes to say Trump
as he likes a China for only $300 okay
man we've been we've been laughing about
all the other rates to China like you
can fly directly to Shanghai for like
300 bucks that's that's rounded
coronavirus is gonna be the answer you
can't say that Oh
you can say it like that but you can't
talk this is YouTube they go you said
you can't say caching but don't say more
than that so what I did okay but what
were you gonna say now do you think the
viral now you can't talk if you can ask
me a question about it otherwise we get
yellowed do you think yeah this
situation yes is gonna be the end of all
cruises I hope so
okay so it's so I see usually not Ted
Cruz Ted Cruz isn't you know that Ted
Cruz is in quarantine Brown I get my
news from then nowadays well I have to
say if you go on a cruise you deserve
anything that happens to you on that
cruise cruising is like the bottom of
the barrel of humanity just think about
whatever I have good friends that like
just went on a cruise and before the end
do they like it though I think so I
think what I've never been on one so I
would never say no I have been on one
when I was like 12 but I didn't find it
let me describe a cruise to you you're
on a boat with a bunch of cheap [ __ ]
you eat at buffets have you seen the
room you're stuck in a time you can't
leave this is the first thing you have
to know romance someone who hasn't been
I can imagine there's probably not a
space Hania tell me about it it's like a
cubicle with just the bed it's like you
got bunk beds and that's your room so
that's where the people that can't leash
it's yeah it's you see sleeping what's
essentially a prison yes it's a prison
I'm in a larger prison at sea you can't
leave that's the thing you can't leave
people call in 20-day cruisers can you
imagine whatever happens to on that see
you have it coming
well a lot of a lot of cruises that they
make stops in like ports and stuff
that's a wire off right that's what we
did it was like this every day was a
stop somewhere
four - left keep that off you get on
well that's what I was a kid you don't
as an adult - everything seems like a
schlep yeah that was what when we were
looking at these ones that are dirt
cheap right now a lot of them yeah are
like the one we saw it was like twenty
two days I can't even if you like
cruises how could you not who's got time
for that
yeah retirees I guess was so wait when
you get off a port in another country do
you have to do like immigration [ __ ] no
I don't know you just get off walk
around security scan because I would
have to be some sort of yeah how there's
gotta be some that's that's my point is
that it's got it because your parents
probably filled it out there's it's
gotta be so annoying because you getting
off in another country you got to do
some kind of declaration and then you
bring [ __ ] back on the cruise you got to
do some kind of declaration
you can't just be coming and going
bringing crazy [ __ ] with you everywhere
yeah I used to sneak booze and Cuban
cigars when I went on that cruise Oh
Zach you're a cruise a veteran I know
that time of my life on a cruise I think
it's fun for kids and old people I was
15 I told everyone I was 17 that's
actually pretty cool good you got to
drink and smoke and stuff like you would
never be able to do yeah yeah plus
that's when I lost my vCard
on a cruise we've I told the story you
didn't tell me that story
that was like the whole blood thing with
the popping of the hymen you didn't
connect how was I supposed to know that
was on a cruise bro how did you seduce a
girl well hold on did you man we're on
the cruise yes it was like was it - I
was Caribbean wait hold on you met her
on the cruise she was from England and
you took her virginity no she took my
virginity
but why was her hymen yeah broken no no
yeah yeah so she's a virgin
yeah what you guys took each other's
virginity on a cruise yeah that's and
then you never saw each other no what oh
my god maybe she's watching right now
Zach how did you meet her how did you
seduce this girl how did you know I mean
I I brought me every thought my guitar
state I did you first meet her where'd
you meet her so they have like a club
thing and it's funny it was a Princess
cruise too and that's the one that's
here right now did you call her a
princess and like if they had like club
things and you know you just go around
and you're up till 4:00 in the morning
or at least I was and I would just take
my guitar all over the cruise and just
play it was like during New Year's too
and like there was a dude playing
bagpipes as well that guy never had a
shot no what's your room also like a
prison completely yeah okay wait wait
you had your own room cuz I'm imagining
you with your parents well no no it was
my grandmother went my parents and then
my brother and I had our own room but
once I started like you know I met this
girl I kicked my brother out of my
parents and your branch knew what was
going on I would assume yeah because why
would their brother be with them yeah
exactly
your parents knew you were you were
screwing some rent girl on the cruise
yeah I mean my dad was cool with it whoa
that's great that's a pretty gnarly
sorry Zach how did you guys have did you
guys do it more than once or was it just
traumatic and then you never did it
again it was traumatic and no no what
was going on yeah what did was she how
was she after you talked to her
afterwards uh yeah I mean it was like I
mean I wasn't like a dick I was like
yeah that happens you know no but like
after so so you guys have this really
crazy oh you mean like laughs stayed
friends yeah yeah she like she got kind
of weird and wanted to start like dating
me and [ __ ] like you got clingy on wow
that's super [ __ ] clinging on the
cruise yeah what were she gonna go it so
hard that I don't crib I don't you guys
had sex way it's weird that she wanted
to be with you after
well well but she maybe she was just
being really like like really clingy I
mean I but you were a stuff on the
cruise so even on the cruise you're like
listen baby you were kind of and off
listen princess I was like you know 15
she thought I was 17 you know so so so
wait you guys had this night the next
day she's intensely wanting to be with
you yeah and then your reaction was was
what you know I wasn't like a dick I was
nice but like I just kind of distanced
myself mmm hung out with other you know
she you know she has distrust of men
ever say I think you single this girl
now now why is it you don't want to
spend any time with her you just weren't
into her and you're just over it I was
freaked out because it just and I
understand I totally understand that Wow
so um crazies are crazy man and like I
met all these people from like Canada
and England where you trying to smash
other girls yeah oh man you are a wild
man and did your parents even ask you
like what was what happened
well I they saw me walking around with
my guitar and like talking to other
girls so they had to assume what was
going on Wow Wow did you smash any other
girls on the person no it was just a few
kisses here and there but dude so that
that I know I never got damn your bald
young man I thought you were pretty big
yeah I was very big I was a freshman in
high school
nice memory Danny thank you thank you
for well I think it is a good detail
yeah you know I was bullied in high
schools yeah this was a pretty awakening
and then Kate's tried man and came back
to you know my shitty life in high
school and you know you're like did I
[ __ ] like 20 girls on this
nobody believes you yeah so wait was
this girl did you was she trying to get
in touch with you during that whole time
I mean was she just kind of went her
separate way when you were flirting with
other girls yeah she kind of took the
hint and you know made like a tree and
leave you know I wasn't a dick I wasn't
like get the [ __ ] out of my face Zack
this is an incredible story do you think
about her do you ever feel bad about how
that went down I do feel bad but I also
feel bad for myself because I was a very
traumatic situation yes
you were definitely the victim this is
such an incredible story
this episode is gone everyone we are
totally off the rails Brickton oh my
goodness I don't want to stop sorry this
conversation is just well zackin is the
sack I love you buddy you give and
giving I was such a nerd at that age
like I had I think I had the opportunity
to have sex at that age but I was I I
felt like I were ready I never seized it
because yeah I guess I wasn't ready yeah
which is weird because that that when
you think of yourself you're like I
don't know I just knew I wasn't ready
somehow I don't know I was not ready to
even make eye contact I was born ready
man watch out for him [ __ ] surprised you
didn't throw her overboard and move on
[Laughter]
all right let's go to a quick break when
we come back we're gonna take a call
from the Philly offense
so the legend the roll patrol and so
stay tuned we'll be right back
if you care about your mouth listen to
the words that I am saying you know that
I live and die by the quip electric
toothbrush it's a vibrating little tube
it's got the softest bristles in the
game to keep your beautiful sensitive
gums that do not grow back by the way
safe and not receding Equipe electric
toothbrush times and pulsates first of
all it vibrates dentists all say
vibrating toothbrushes clean better
here's the trick though here's why it's
so cool it pulsates and it tells you
when to switch quadrants to make sure
you get that perfect two minute dentist
recommended brush every time you brush
your mouth
thirty Seconds murmur switch 30 seconds
we're airing switch
that's why quip is amazing it keeps your
mouth clean and it keeps you in good
shape my dudes quip also has a floss
dispenser that comes with pre marks
string to help you use just enough make
that easier on you plus quip delivers
fresh breasts head brush heads I can't
say brush what do we keep saying breath
bus brush heads they deliver fresh brush
heads floss and toothpaste refills to
your door every three months with free
shipping so your routine is always right
and you're not pathetically sitting
there rolling tooth paper like rolling
toothpaste out of thin air have you ever
been that low on toothpaste and you're
like please God just one dollop that's
all I need you're squeezing with all
your might that will never happen to you
with quit join over 3 million healthy
mouths and get equipped today starting
at just $25 and if you got a get quip
calm slash h3 right now you'll get your
first refill for free so that's your
first refill free at get quip calm slash
h3 spelled GE t qu i p.com slash h3
that's quip the good habits company
welcome back everybody today we've got
on the line
the infamous Philly offensive aka eight
roll Patrol the man who stole our hearts
and minds who had us all divided as a
real it's a fake who knows we found out
in the end
through an admission of hims oh not
really an admission wasn't hiding
anything
he's a sketch he's a sketch comedian
which we were all blown away to find out
I want to jog your memory before we
bring him on the line this is Rolle
patrolled the video that that captivated
all of our hearts minds
[Music]
yo bro
you suppose we'll use the wax paper when
you touch the rolls
I'm role patrol dude no but seriously
the wax paper and you're sniffing them
and then you're touching them and you're
putting them back
they smell like [ __ ] this exchange just
real the ones you touched and buy them
because I don't want I don't want it I
don't know where your dick beaters bends
you mean
[Music]
listen cuz pick them the [ __ ] up and put
them in your bag or I'm going to even
you up
[Music]
I'm Tony right now he's look at like
he's scared right so convincing pick him
up
it's disgusting I know
[Music]
so use the wax paper next time dude so
good it's so good it's so brilliant I
have so many questions for the JJ also
known as the Philly offensive so without
further ado Dan can we get our boy JJ
Philly offensive on the line and here we
are with the Philly offensive JJ is that
right is that what I should call you
yeah JJ works welcome I do it how are
you let me ask you something the roll
patrol had captivated our hearts and
minds we did it we were almost none of
us first suspected that it was fake at
all
I tell run me through the production of
that video so that's my buddy Jim he was
in a couple videos of mine and I went to
meet him and we went to Home Depot to
try to get an apron to do a video there
and we were told to just walk into the
break room and steal one and we didn't
feel comfortable doing that so I was
like alright well let's just go down
there was an ACME down the street let's
go down there and do this roll video
because I hate seeing that yeah you know
it uh it just drives me crazy and I'll
be honest I never say anything when it
comes to the rolls I mean yeah so you're
not patrolling in your free time
right certain things I will speak up
though like in a lot of my videos I I
speak up it's because it's how I feel
like I'm very feel very passionate about
that certain things like littering or
you know someone hitting a doll or
mistreating an animal but anyway we went
in and he was super nervous Jim because
he hasn't been in a video in a while and
I remember making his eye black
I wanted it black her but he was
shakin putting this ink on his eye but I
guess it looked black enough because you
know when when I said I'll even you to
[ __ ] up people understood what I meant
his nervousness was so III was for sure
like the look that he gave you was so
genuine I thought for sure was real and
I thought I'm gonna be honest I thought
you are a huge black guy or something
that wasn't like a mobility a scooter or
something and you stood up and just
scared the [ __ ] out of him well yeah the
way I was holding my phone I shoot all
my videos on my phone it did look like
that it's like after we shot it when he
laughed at the end I'm not a failure I'm
like man how no and I was like you know
what like there was people watching us
and by the way we did by the roles he
sniffed oh yeah very good you didn't
become the PERT the monster you despised
and I loved the line the role smells
like [ __ ] now how bland is that what did
was that improviser did you say tell
tell me the role smell like [ __ ] I just
said sniff him and he went with it dude
what a legend and who's someone behind
this recording who's that that's Kristen
oh my girl she's chasing the dog I
creepy hi
you don't sniff rolls and put him back
deal kids dogs babies and put them back
no she's not that person
yeah that would never work out between
they tell you have a feeling if she was
so it do you fool a lot of people into
thinking your videos are real but it
seems like you are so talented at making
the semi realism kind of sketches that
yeah I've had the steak is for taxpayers
that was the first one back in 2015 and
that was the first viral video I made
meaning like I remember I can't remember
like yesterday because it was like so
shocked
I posted it at like 8:00 p.m. and by
8:05 and had 50,000 likes wow are we
talking about on Facebook or where and
then but I and most of them like the
roll Patrol one take one take it's done
yeah same with steak is for taxpayers so
on so you're private right you're
primarily on Facebook because on YouTube
I noticed the views are quite low yeah
I really didn't focus on YouTube they
removed me I used to have a real big
problem trolling people respond to every
comment like it's one yeah [ __ ] you it
didn't work out because it just makes
people more mad and the same thing with
Facebook I've probably had about five
different accounts now and certain
videos they always go viral you know and
I learned my lesson and so are you able
to make money at all to people are you
making money on Facebook I sell
merchandise but now that Facebook has
the monetization option which they
didn't before mail there'll be you know
a huge potential to make money yes so
you didn't you weren't able to make
money because those videos are old but
now you do have active Facebook page
that you want people to come visit and
follow absolutely it's the Philly
offenses Philly offensive well I think
it's a goddamn shame you're not a
billionaire by now I think you should be
a billionaire I'm being honest skip
their Millions
and and do you find your videos get
stolen posted around a lot now if you go
on Facebook and just type in the Philly
offensive there's so many that are you
know posted and most people that I you
know if I might go can you give me
credit they'll be like oh I'm sorry I
didn't know it was yours but people like
worldstar and all they posted them
countless times and yeah you can't get
ahold
people I mean yes a whole engine of
theft they're really not even stealing
rolls they're just stealing videos which
is arguable even worse worse yeah and
can I ask you of all your videos because
I've only seen you have a lot of these
little sketches which is your favorite
which is the one that you recommend that
we go watch now after this video is over
if you have one I would say besides got
milk the one with the drugs in an arcane
yeah just it real quick the only people
that were with me was the guy overdosing
yeah Mike broke oh and the guy who got
kicked my buddy Pat oh other people were
doing exactly what they were doing
before I asked him to be in a video oh
my god they were sold it so that is that
my reality yeah legit there and one guy
was running around he kept screaming
what the [ __ ] oh my god he's like what
do you want me to say I was he just keep
saying what the [ __ ] hey so is this
whole concept like what's with them yeah
what is how did you come up with the
idea to pour milk in the mouth of
someone Oh Dean I find that to be so
specific
I am almost convinced me it was real I I
see I think I seen a meme or something
or no no it was a video where someone
was overdosing on dust angel dust
yeah and they somebody said you need
milk for some milk and some yeah for the
guy to get kicked in the nuts yes that
videos my masterpiece truly I really
appreciate that and I really appreciate
you put me out there and I would say the
best video to check out is
do you have health insurance oh okay I
love the titles yeah I'm gonna look at
that one um let me think I think we're
gonna watch it right after this call cuz
I want to know what I'm missing
okay so the the one I just posted I
think it's it's about dog poop dog this
one was played on MTV
did they pay today credit you they did
they did not they didn't pay they won't
mention my name I asked them MTV yeah
the show ridiculousness
yeah how can they show your [ __ ] and not
even ask for your consent they don't oh
no no I got paid for that okay okay they
want to plug though you know why because
they wanted to all pretend like it was
real probably right and they said their
producer said we do not we don't credit
websites did they pay you fairly you got
a good nice little check from them no no
of course yeah I don't man what's your
goal with with this stuff you just want
to continue like making sketches and
comedy yeah I mean I you know I I've
been doing it so long like I mean I've
been doing it before social media just
messing with people and then and then I
found this platform where I've reached
so far that I would love to like you
know have something on Netflix or
absolutely you know something like that
but uh yes check out um do you have
health insurance and the other one is
picket to [ __ ] up they're the best I'll
think about that
I was at the mall tear garbage no no
this is dog [ __ ] yeah I can tell that
all these are inspired from your
everyday life yeah oh yeah if I see
someone letting their dog crap and they
walk away I'm saying something how does
that usually go down probably
more polite than what's depicted in the
videos I'm assuming or maybe not depends
how I feel ah yeah honestly you know I
mean I'm not a tough guy but when it
comes to like you know you're gonna
leave your dog crap on my payment and
walk away like no you're gonna pick it
up I am with you a thousand percent I'm
gonna wash these I'm gonna watch these
segments lastly let's plug we've got the
the Philly offensive you can find JJ
everywhere people are found is that
right that's right okay to Facebook you
tell I don't need to spread I would like
to keep in touch with you I think you're
a hilarious dude and I'm trying to think
of ways that I I want to pay you more
than ridiculousness pay deal and I want
to try to think of a way that we can
work together hey man that's another
goal is to write for someone so oh wow
nice so but if I'm guessing on what
ridiculous paid you then I'll be then
probably for like 20 bucks per sketch
does that sound good if I'm trying to
tell you more and finally well as a
token of gratitude I just I want to do
something that's you are you and your
girlfriend they're interested in going
on a cruise and I send you on a cruise
or maybe a round trip to Shanghai we're
just giving out gifts you know it
doesn't sound like I like that's what
you do to your enemy let me take you on
a route we were just looking up cruises
the guys found to 8:20 night cruise for
$300 to China so if you and your
girlfriend should I'd be happy to front
the money
[Laughter]
everybody round-trip all expenses paid
no I actually I value you too much I
want you around I want you we can't
afford you being in quarantine all right
that's right all right well JJ thank you
so much for the
wonderful content thank you for calling
us and thank you we'll be in touch
I think you're amazing dude and you're
doing God's work out there so thank you
thank you thank you both thank you thank
you all right thank you god bless
what a joy what a treat the Philly
offensive I have a feeling that is not
the last time we will be hearing from
him he recommended these two videos I
want to watch them he recommended do you
have health insurance I haven't seen
either of these so this is exciting
try again dude you try again my man you
taking up you taking up two spaces no
listen listen yo they're here for a
reason they draw these lines here yeah
the PTO the people that are organized
and have common sense yeah listen
yo my man listen you got health
insurance why because if you don't get
in that [ __ ] car and report your car
you're gonna need it
all right just get in the car you're
[ __ ] everything up someone's gonna
want to park here and they came
un-fuckin'-believable they're all these
they're all these blinds for a reason
not good no no you must have sucked at
coloring right you know he it's really
just acting out the fantasy that we all
have when we see someone doing something
like that and it's and I love it
it's cathartic it's like a it's like the
same energy as like curb kind of wounds
like a cathartic like yeah what we all
wish we could say mm-hmm
very true there was one other one here
it is pick that [ __ ] up all right calm
down let me know the same people
yeah I'll be right back baby Wow show up
that minute yeah hey hey hey listen you
were here last week and you let your dog
[ __ ] on my payment the same you just did
you need to pick that up
it's a chihuahua okay I don't care if
it's a chihuahua or a [ __ ] Great Dane
when I step in it all right I got kids
in there when I bring it and step in and
bring it in my house the kids are
rolling around in it you mean okay so
you need to pick it [ __ ] up listen
you're gonna pick it up I'm gonna knock
your junkie boyfriend the [ __ ] you
really pick at your [ __ ]
no picket the latrine oh yeah it's bad
with their hands yeah over people that
are like so committed I mean the guy's a
genius
he's got a talent he does I could
totally see a TV show
well like I said I am gonna do I want
him I want him to be I'm gonna do
everything in my power which is very
little man I hope he doesn't run into
Zach on that cruise I'm sending them
both on a cruise zach is gonna go on the
cruise I can't get over the Zach Cruise
story still in my mind let's move on to
our main oh I wanted to talk about this
actually before we move on to my main
segment of the day Wiki feet before we
do I wanted to show this really funny
chain of events that happened recently
you guys saw Khloe Kardashian she posted
I paid partnership with Febreze
first of all weird I mean who's twice
Febreze even doing like influencer
marketing it's Febreze it's not cool you
know what I mean
but here's she posts a picture but they
have like diamond covered bottles yeah
yeah it's like rhinestone what are you
supposed to do with that it's just bling
bro it's just like it's like just bomb
its Febreze
it's for stoners and for hiding the
smell of [ __ ] you know what I mean so
here she is on her bed with a bunch of
Febreze so I said when you [ __ ] the bed
which which was funny I thought dude
wipes you know this is a company I've
seen on Shark Tank oh yeah they make
wipes for dudes and they call mitad
and they said now is this is good
advertising I it with like one hand
because I was holding Theodore or
something that's why like there's a
period and I was like where's our dude
wipe sponsorship and they DM me and they
said that they were down to sponsor me I
was like holy [ __ ] dude weird let's do
I've never I don't think I've ever done
a sponsored tweet because yeah we maybe
did like one or two on Instagram but
that's it right I did it a long time ago
yeah I did not like that though where
it's like Haley I remember we did one
for like the video movie or something I
thought I was off a video game I don't
remember it was awhile ago anyway so I
thought this is great I'm going to do
this with dude wipes so this was the the
end result was me on the bed with a
bunch of nude wives and I don't know if
you noticed the detail here a dirty wipe
growth sexy you mean and it's titled now
dude wipes has me covered when I [ __ ]
the bed somebody paid me to do this I
thought it was awesome
some people were wondering if you were
wearing underwear and there yeah you can
see my under can you I mean I was
wearing boxers I wanted it to look I
wanted you to see as much leg as
possible like her I got a fat thigh bro
I'm [ __ ] fat but anyway lots of
compliments on your legs I think they
were probably goofs cuz I got fat legs
back maybe so okay I'll take it you know
how to take a compliment that's what
this learn to take all that well we
tried our best to match it so I think we
did a pretty good job what do you think
yeah but like going through this I mean
this this whole premise of this photo is
so stupid yeah and how much money did
they pay her for this I bet you they
paid her like half a million dollars for
this Febreze I got paid substan
got paid substantially less
I did this for the gifts I think dude
wife's got a better deal than the edge
then Febreze I don't get worried what do
you do with the rhinestone bottle like
when you when you're done do you use
this Febreze with the crazy bottle or do
you what are you supposed to show it off
in your house yeah I think it's designed
to make you feel like you're doing your
elevating the experience of masking the
smell of [ __ ] because it's not a lady
thing to do
so you compete Khloe Kardashian and
still be for breezing [ __ ] she I hate
them I really do I'm sorry and I just I
just despise this I really despise
everything about this you're on a bed
with Febreze bottles like who [ __ ]
cares god I mean it does it bother
anyone as much as it bothers me this
photo you know it's so stupid
why is Febreze what the campaign doesn't
make sense
why is Febreze the caption what's the
caption I'll tell you for Twitter right
now and it's all sponsored by the way
way back this is from before so this I
posted on February I think it was
February 26 I think I or the day before
I think it was on Instagram no she
posted everywhere for some reason I I
don't have a link to the original photos
yeah but it was so I do remember what it
was it was something like something like
wow for Bri imma for Brees partner for
life I can't believe how great it smells
and I just squirted all my bits for like
squirting on your bed or something okay
which is why my joke was so funny
regula Paradis so you found it yeah so
you wanna go ahead and read it 1 million
and 100 likes who would like that poster
I mean genuinely even if you're a fan of
her
but listen to the copy like D it's like
haunted - like she cares so little about
her like her audience she thinks there's
such sheep that she it's so obvious she
didn't write this and yet people still
liked it
listen to this I mean it's pretty just
like transparent that it's an ad she
didn't really try to make it but why
would you like what you've engage with
this heart the best ever I've used at
Febreze fabric on my bed for years try
it out and let me know what you think
crowned king of a crown hashtag Febreze
partner forever buy my favorite scent at
but I don't find it particularly dumber
than about this photo here she is in the
Swiss Alps with Febreze she out on her
balcony getting but but breeze do you
need in your house why is there a breeze
everywhere what pisses me off more about
not just these advertised posts but just
always the comments from like not just
her in particular but like mega
superstars people on the level of her
yeah he's just looking at like the top
responses like from like I guess I have
to be logged in to see cuz I just see
the plebs
Kim Kardashian and her sister I need
that rhinestone bottle you've been using
this forever neat freak
so I my theory on that Dan is that that
comment is part of the disk part of it
yeah probably at least from her but like
OMG this is iconic I use it too I think
they're all paid to say that which is
actually even more insidious because
they don't I don't think you need to
disclose would that be Rossum if they
had to start disclosing and they go oMG
I need this - hashtag add I don't think
the comments are paid for but I think
it's their way of supporting each other
because they know I would
anyone say oh my god I need that foot
breeze too because there is it pouring
oh yeah Wow
yeah it's like mega porn I want to look
good
well too bad you got a show to do wait
it's dude it's so loud is it like anyway
boring no it's gnarly it's like really
coming down I don't know II think in
here it was so exciting
they hold on so we we hear it on the
mics yeah we'll definitely hear that oh
yeah yeah - what's like a low Rumble I
didn't know there was expected so much
rain um anyway I was saying I don't
think the comments are paid I think
they're just supporting each other girls
party girls what about the sisters so
here's a photo of her she's here's a
photo of those who reminds me of the
Tyra Banks write your own Vaseline this
one is even worse it's because the
Vaseline you can carry with you and you
like take it out it's a beauty product
kind of rabies what do you do with this
it doesn't look good it's not like I
would live it out for decoration I just
can't cook I'm sorry you guys this just
bothers me a lot hmm Febreze I mean how
much would it be expensive to bedazzle
whole bodies a full body of Febreze and
all that's inside is like [ __ ] water
with chemicals in it all right so dude
why shut up - dude wipes thank you I
thought we did it pretty good and I
stoked to get paid to goof on Chloe
Clair - Ian Clark - Ian another in other
Twitter news Oh Jay Simpson they thought
it was impossible I was challenged by
someone to get blocked by OJ Simpson and
I frankly didn't think was possible
because every response on all of his
tweets is just relentless clowning on
him and so I figured there's no way he
even goes into the comments because it's
just so brewed
but here we go I was blocked by OJ
Simpson he posts himself in front of
Costco he said coronavirus who's afraid
he's got a mask on and a shopping cart
full of toilet paper and I was like oh J
wait he had the toilet paper yes he's
one of the people okay and I said to him
well statistically I prime a have a
better chance of being killed by you
than the virus because you know in my
age bracket I don't I don't think many
people died but OJ has killed two people
at least so two statistically he is more
deadly to me than the virus I thought it
was a valid observation to make and OJ
blocked me so there you go I achieved
the impossible Oh Jay Simpson I'm on his
kill list now yes okay we uh well I'm
sad I can't be with sweets anymore so
you guys are gonna have to keep me
updated if anything goes on there nope
dude alt for all these people blocking
you I can't manage all these I can't
manage all these Twitter accounts but uh
the people have spoken Eva and as
238,000 like so it's a hit on Twitter
yeah
oh is Jake Paul but they've all blocked
me unprovoked it wasn't what I mean what
I mean by incidents I think there was I
showed you one oh that I tell ya I just
don't think you realize that he blocked
you at the time right probably
relegations probably the relentless
mocking for three years straight well
that could be true I'm not sure I would
probably block me if I could can I block
myself be good hila blocked me last
night in real life I mean apologies
so that's exciting I was kind of proud
to be frank then the woman and what's
funny is that you know he read it so
it's funny he's like I already thought
this guy got me good or he's like man
idea I didn't kill anyone
no he knows he killed someone he's like
damn everybody just wants to talk about
that I murdered two people and not that
I'm buying toilet paper from Costco
isn't it so crazy that he's just out
cruising around and joined life yes it
is Tom Segura left a funny comment I
posted on Instagram and he goes he's
like excuse me Oh Jay Simpson was
acquitted in a court of law show some
respect
and people were all like I guess who
didn't know who Tom was really he's
joking to calm down I can't believe
you're defending OJ is good aids will
anyway Oh Jay Simpson blocked me that
was very epic and before one more thing
before we get to wiki feet you uh I have
one entry for worst tattoo as you will
note ela has a very strong opinion that
bent Kathleen has the worst tattoo in
the world and this one our subreddit
it's someone they have zippers on the
back of their leg that opens up into a
camo pattern I don't understand it is so
bad why do they have a mall under their
skin I don't know the zipper is so ugly
too I just I don't get the the message
the message in their skin like what does
it mean
the skin is over the camel is the skin
there cam out there pretending to be
human but they're actually they're
actually a soldier actually a soldier I
don't get it because soldiers have skin
to the heart of a warrior it's really
sophisticated and it's also wearing
flip-flops which is a very warrior ass
I'm just saying wait that's a sheet you
know what do you mean he that's like
female right that makes it even worse
I agree laugh at the bottle where's it
stop the bottle I think this one is
might be the worst really oh don't make
any sense it's so it's so ballsy I mean
so bold and it's so nonsensical it's
huge it's ugly
still getting images by the way how did
this end up in the Getty Getty Images
archive so this is another celeb no no
way I should get everything man how was
this a Getty Images archive I refuse to
believe that also I think the Ben
Affleck tattoo kind of Lee headed out of
the what was under the green part Oh
interesting
um since I kind of heard his story that
it didn't actually lie about the tattoo
his writing is kind of changing for me
you just feel bad for him yeah you saw
yeah he's in tough shape that poor Ben
yeah tough shape and he actually seems
like an okay guy yeah you know he's an
alcohol well whatever I don't care I'm
not I don't care about gossip and let's
see youtuber of course been a lot down
I'm all about it but okay so because to
me that was one of the factors he lied
about it yeah yeah and I thought that
was so funny but once I understood it
was like sticking it to the paparazzi
people yeah those can't blame him for
doing the visit um yeah so um but what
is this tattoo mean this one is way
uglier and actually you cannot really
hide it even like as a female she's
gonna wear I mean she's wearing short
pants in the summer she thinks it's
awesome
well you know what she does she's trying
to appeal to some like she's probably in
like Arkansas and she wants some redneck
to think that's the coolest thing ever
some Budweiser drink and redneck don't
want to mount her like a stallion
someone will think that it's the coolest
thing ever
right there is someone for that to to
and I just and I just I'm not trying to
get I'm just saying you know
I don't have to put this but you know
whoever thought this tattoo was awesome
and you know whoever got this tattoo you
know who they vote for political I'm
just saying I just think it's
interesting but you but don't you find
it interesting you know did somebody who
would [ __ ] this and think it was awesome
with both Trump and I'm not saying
that's a bad thing it's just you know
using someone that would mount this with
vote Democrat ever am I going is this
funny or abettor stupid then you telling
them we're not going no it's not meant
to be cheap shot you think it's mmm it's
not that funny I guess
mmm cheap shot no good yeah
are we in revolt yeah you asked no I
want the honest truth
I don't want to know if I should abort
or personal board board's acting in you
guys all think abort step up guys come
on
yeah board but do you agree it's funny
it's funny it's not funny I like it I
don't like it I don't like it I don't
like it I like it I like it I like it
everything I like country I don't know
way to call
can we just talk about it too - I want
to talk about feet especially all day to
talk about this feet well here's affair
what do you think of this one
ice room show I promise it's again the
show I problems with doing a show keep
it wholesome and light okay but I just
thought I was like you know what
nope yeah okay let's move on let's talk
about Wiki feet which is what we've all
been waiting for
now camel and a zipper in the back of
the leg you know what I wish I wish that
whoever made Wicky fit would make Wicky
tattoos mmm rating of the table you
can't you have because you can pee it
off two feet and therefore it's more
popular
of course so there's a site called wiki
feet now blows my mind first of all that
this site exists it's a Wikipedia
dedicated you can find any celebrity big
or small pictures of their feet on this
website and apparently has a very active
community because they have like a whole
catalogue
I mean it's so dedicated for example I
looked myself up and I'm thinking to
myself I have never I don't think I've
ever shown my feet I say I can't recall
one time I've ever shown my feet on
camera yet when I post it up these guys
sought it out click on every photo and
sure enough I was like oh yep yeah and
but like here this is like today is the
money shot but are you sure that people
are jerking off to feet why else are
they on wiki feed there there's no
reason for this website to exist if
they're not masturbating I don't know
guys
guys speak up because the men there's no
women masturbating on this website only
men are sick enough to do this game what
what damn I don't know about that this
is your look at your own wiki for gay
men women would never masturbate to this
I'm sorry you can call me judgmental a
woman or would not come here and
masturbate to a man's feet I it's gay
dudes we're gonna get multiple emails
now dude no no emails I'm calling it it
may be like I'm saying 99% men on this
I'm just saying guys we'll only
disgusting enough people on said jerk
off the feet maybe I don't know I mean
it's all it's all bizarre to me so it's
hard for me yeah so Zach do you have a
thing for feet
I feel like Zach might know not in the
end be honest with me and don't lie to
me no I don't really get it I gotta be
honest I don't get it I kind of hate it
I don't hate feet but I start like an
aversion to it yeah but I'm certainly
not into it I don't definitely like not
look at it I kind of avoid looking at
the sobolik so I'm not a sex I
by any means but people have gone
through my videos and found this
specific frame where you can see my foot
the best your ratings pretty good dude
look at that
well whoa I have to in Milan over four
stars I have to admit that I am so it's
a four-point for it there's a lot of
well you'll see I mean I I'm wow that's
some nice feet man well thank you very
much Dan I take steroids writer III
Frank I do I do think I have nice feet
if I may say so here's what confuses me
about all of this so and I guess we'll
we'll see as we continue I'm so baffled
by all this I I don't even understand
the rubric like I am not really sure
what makes a foot nice like obviously if
it's like really then I think women can
be pretty judgmental of feet no but they
don't jerk off to feet they don't
masturbate to but you decided that this
is a jerk off website I'm not sure
that's true Wiki feet are you bro I
think that women are voting here why
would any woman come to this site just
for a hobby why what are they doing here
these are dudes with their hand on their
penis jerking off I'm I I'm so sure I'm
so sure you guys have to see what I'm
talking about backstage I see what
you're talking about but I think they
you would be surprised that it's not the
only thing happening here I could only
give to know who's been on the side you
know what I mean I would love to see the
demographic how many ratings do you have
oh it's only 15 votes wait where do you
see the votes I just I pulled it up it's
on the top right but that's a lot for me
right who's coming to my page I don't
know where do you see this on the top
right of the website my rating stats 15
total vote oh yeah here no I have no 1
or 2 stars that's pretty good yeah a lot
of average people say I'm just average
so about 8 5 stars that's very good ok
by the way and by the way by the way you
have to login to vote so these are
people who have an active yeah so I'm
just saying there's this and there's no
reason just wrote no no no no it says
you have to
again Wonka here let me refresh just to
prove it Oh what they just I just saw
that uh I'm on your page the suggestive
one is PewDiePie and he has almost a
perfect score yes so what I've noticed
about it is let me just go computed by
here there's a lot of foot shots I think
it's really just based on how attractive
people find them I don't think it really
has aimed to do with their actual feet I
could be wrong but PewDiePie here's a
4.96 you'll notice throughout this that
some people have a 5.5 and I don't know
how that's power
but some people I yeah how could you go
over five you'll see that oh is it six
stars in total what no it's fine you'll
see but let's see I mean how would you
rate those either yeah I mean yeah
nothing no weird hits shapes but I think
you had a lot of feed pics did I think
oh so many people's jerk to this so many
right so anyway let's get off Felix he's
not part of the game plan so then I says
okay well obviously eva must have one
witch but then i was like i also never
show my there's no weight you know ever
showed her feet like I'm on Cameron way
more dude look on me feed pics there are
view ela crazy it's from your like look
you have a hundred of five ratings
people are jerking off to your feet 105
ratings and it for some reason on the
female side it doesn't say this specific
number but it says you have four and a
half stars
oh you're right beautiful beautiful
maybe they don't want body shame the
women but look how many feet shots there
are the shoe size seven us is that
accurate
seven seven us wait um do you do you
want me know um oh I can edit it you
want me to correct it here I can change
it is this
I mean I'm assuming women's size right
now I'm nine you're nine okay we've just
updated it but you gotta be like me oh
you know like yeah I love that anyone
can change it can you believe how many
feet photo yeah but you know it's not
that many they take like screenshots
from one thing I know but still and
you've got a hundred this is your fault
those are your Instagram stories oh my
I'm not thinking about you your feet are
in the shot and let me see wait where's
the money shot like if I'm trying to
jerk off your feet which is the one I
was there mmm probably one of these huh
Hey look how pregnant I am and I know I
would probably jerk off to this one cuz
you sounding like someone that would
almost jerk off to fit I'm just I'm yeah
well I'm putting my mind you know I'm
putting my mind then maybe this one too
it's like a weird like there's like a
weird like so weird
corpse fetish where is this what is god
it's from our dumb products video right
I'll see there you go mm-hmm yeah I jerk
off to your feet okay so but then I'm
like okay mean you're on there dj khaled
I look up next dj khaled three he's got
a three so dj khaled they've got all his
feet and then I says to myself okay John
Jafari
jontron I start looking at my friends
poor John he's got a three point three
not many shots here's one you can't
really see much yeah but this one oh you
can't really see anything
well they've they've stamped in with the
three point three they said no to John's
feet then I look up items idubbbz is one
of these beautiful feet it has over a
five and I don't know how that's
possible he has a 5.3 five out of five I
don't get that
yeah what that bothers me
this website is not making any sense it
throws it all in the questions you know
but limp but okay his feet are so much
more beautiful than mine let's have a
look so if I was jerking off to his feet
which one when I choose of this one for
sure he'll discuss time it's kind of a
weird look I feel like my feet are more
beautiful than his why does his good why
does his feet get a better rating than
mine I think people are just here's a
good shot on the bottom left a you jerk
well no I mean where you can really not
that one this yeah that's where you can
really see his fit nobody see people who
drink off to this it won't like the
really [ __ ] disgust to him because I
think the foot fetish that's according
to you I listen I think it's about the
fact that it's disgusting no I don't
think you even know what you're talking
about all right keep looking right in
and say he was right and he was wrong
okay everyone tell me what's up with his
foot [ __ ] but I think my feet are more
beautiful than Ian so they're and he's a
5.3 five well he seems to have hacked
the system or something extraordinary so
we we are accusing in of sabotaging his
wiki feat for sure possibly buying votes
yeah well I wouldn't put it past him he
is vain like that Philip DeFranco wiki
feat a three point six eat it Philip Wow
I use alike
why he looked jacked his legs like
jacked look at him
let me get a look at his feet let me see
you yes he I gotta be honest Philip I
probably wouldn't masturbates here
please if that was my thing just being
honest right
it almost looks like it's kind of been
off like the two onions back in that
picture Wow oh it's a good yeah so
Philip DeFranco has less beautiful feet
than me I'm happy to say owned own thank
you Dan
Daniel came for a friend of the show
obviously 4.6 now this I'm gonna have to
login to Ray to one cuz who is it
he has seven votes yeah I'm star yeah
this came star his name's Daniel oh yeah
no I didn't know we're gonna have to
luck
can we Brigade his wiki feat it's only
seven votes we could swing this
okay so Zach and in and Dan I want you
guys to log in a wiki feats and give him
one star okay
yeah I'm just getting on it no I'm on
that back is a 4.6 I mean come on yeah
they're not bad feet honestly III I'm
not gonna hate on the guy I would I was
squirted on him on his feet I can't even
see this for you this one I was in the
bottom they're not that bad
pretty regular yep they're rigged I'm
not gonna hit on his feet you can hate
the man but love the feet I've learned
that through life of law
so then jennamarbles starting to look at
the females
jenna Marbles has a perfect five star
rating oh I actually only pull this up
because it's too weird but I wanted to
show like this Oh God or she you did
like her oh no and that that's how you
get a five star now that's hot that's
actually terrifying she has a lot of
feed pics man look at Jesus Jenna that's
pretty funny though oh no wonder she's
got five stars she's given the people
just what they want you know what I mean
like damn and I don't look to launch of
that because it is weird cuz we know her
but now I want to get funny okay we know
all these people yeah but it's weird cuz
you like I'm obviously joking what to do
is but I feel like people spend a lot of
time on Jenna's jerking off not me I'm
not into that you know I'm not why would
I do that
she has 700 votes so this is like a high
traffic page you know so there's that so
now let's say okay Shaq hmm Shaquille
O'Neal funny he's getting hated on he's
the lowest rate I've ever seen one point
one
you guys what 11.1 was looking for more
I figured because he famously has like
massive feet so it's Getty Images they
own everything and oh my god yeah that's
what I understand though it's just like
him people that are into feet don't like
big feet or something I would assume if
you were into a foot fetish you would
want to see you like like a big foot
you know like anything like I don't
think that's too large it could fit look
at this he's got a one point one
everybody agrees he has awful feet like
everybody who's in the feet everybody
who knows anything about feet here's
some poor won't Asian woman his foots
the size of her whole body but they're
not it that bad for like a one-star is
that's what I'm saying it's no I agree
it seems super harsh I don't know what
the frig normal oh those are hideous
that's bad news right almonds dude wait
there's comments yes scroll down wait
where how do i scroll down bro there's
comments oh I've been missing that
there's comments top comment I feel
nauseated looking at his feet from the
looks of it he seems I've been stuffing
his feet and his shoes way too small one
of his big toes is leaning too far over
like it may have been crushed inside of
shoes then there's the fungus infected
big toe which caused him to have no
toenail absolutely hideous
nasty vomit inducing these look like
FEMA I was about to say this dispels
your theory here wait
why cause her name's foxy feet yeah that
looks like I don't got a guy am I gonna
click Oh her use afraid she's a user
rating it shows one-star ugly feet she
did talk no no I think that that's oh
that's her rating a fan yeah exactly and
this is like a comment that was left
along with that rating wait now I got to
I need to go tonight name that cramming
big feet is so I
or is so common ruins otherwise large
and beautiful feet along is a prime
example of this so see I'm starting to
get a sense of see there are just
criticizing the Fate but they don't like
the cramming yeah so we need we need to
get big beautiful feet that don't cramp
that's the objective Americas like I got
to go back and see if there's comments
on like years anyway there was I wasn't
gonna point it out but well let's see it
why weren't oh god they're links oh no
that uh oh I got a feeling Ethan's gonna
be roasting this site down the line here
we are
oh [ __ ] this was from four years ago
took us a while man I'm surprised - it's
not wait that's November 16th of last
year I mean I was really sick Steen and
I uh well usually put the year last and
yeah the order is weird but it's this
would have been made a great HD video no
way Eli's this a seven and that's true
I'm tall okay these people are so
dedication size eleven at least yeah oh
I didn't I told you bro didn't I tell
you this was the one that I would jerk
off to this person says foot artist I
feel like I've completed my journey on
this site and they tagged this photo
that's the one they nodded to that's ela
I totally called that oh then this is
the other one I cut I called out there
saying where are these words this
picture from they want to know what rape
dungeon I don't know what to tell you
would have loved to serve under her
command with feet like her she'd have
had no trouble keeping me in line I'm
telling these are dudes jerking off you
okay but I think one comes to the guys I
think girls
well actually commenting on the
aesthetic of the foot regardless of what
your name right let's look into it but
this comment says your savior thank you
so much his gorgeous long time Oh gross
do that's 2017 that was 2016 Wow wait so
wait now I gotta see the comments I'm
fine oh my god I wonder there's got to
be no comments right yeah there's no
comments huh I just gave chemo one star
by the way meantime we check his rating
you shouldn't know you this process is
wholesome you shouldn't you shouldn't do
that he says the four points - no I was
kidding I said he took it back I took it
back they still have four point six
maybe it takes a while [ __ ] is gross all
right get that off me let's move on to
the funny things okay now everybody's on
here Oh actually Trish uh Michael Phelps
has a weirdest feet ever and yet people
love him for point eight
yeah this was the other thing that
confused me it was like he had the
weirdest feet ever bro look at this
photo look how look his feet they look
like fingers huh they look like
skeletons yeah I thought to light him up
because I knew that about him he
famously has like because Y is like the
best swimmer in the world
yeah his feet and his hands are like
massive they're like paddles it's why
swim so fast oh my God look at this
photo and tell me you wouldn't nut like
made for four feet fish
so anyway people do like his feet so
what are the comments here because it's
literally a bunch of women I don't think
so
this is a dude good swimmers have good
and big flippers and Phelps are some of
the nicest big feet I've seen telling
else need to be manicured better but
otherwise beautiful shape now that I
think of it one of my exes was the
swimmer and had the most beautiful big
feet I've seen his toenails were much
this is a gay dude we're much better
manicured and toes were thicker it has a
male avatar
it's just the default yeah yeah okay and
here's a picture of a dude I'm sorry but
the tops of his feet are terrible yeah
cuz people are picky on oh my god this
is just so weird you guys I would like
he was my very first heavy foot crush
after all these years I'm still totally
fascinated and hypnotized by his giant
elves this is a gay guy that's from
young foot lover now can we all agree
okay yes this is men these are all men I
mean I think in Michael Phelps case it
is okay fine let's agree on that point
yeah so now we're moving on I say okay
they have everybody on this website I
want to put that to the test
what does everybody mean well let me
show you
Charles Manson has a wiki feed page one
star based on this one photo but they
found it Charles Manson has a feed pic
and they found it can you believe Harvey
Weinstein is no bucky feet he actually
doesn't have a one star sum but he has
four believe it or not kirbo are five
star ratings well but ultimately he has
a 5 a 1 point 5 and here's Harvey on the
beach a paparazzi photo only comment
disgusting feet for a disgusting human
being crap but why does Getty Images
even on these like what what is wrong
with Getty Images what the f is going on
with Getty Images my whole business they
own paparazzi photos of Harvey Weinstein
on the beach hello who's consuming these
the media them or whatever you know Wow
Trump has a 1 star rating there's only
one known picture of his feet he's
sitting on a throne of a swan in a white
suit this is a bizarre photos the thing
I've ever seen
that is very strange he's no this is
just so weird
and he's got bad feet apparently so you
won't really want a president with
one-star feet okay let's let's put it
this way without getting political
Donald Trump has one star Joe Biden on
the other hand let's see what Joe Biden
has no results oh no Joe okay but then
let's look at Bernie
ya know Joe um Bernie no Bernie Sanders
Wow I think Donald Winston cuz he's long
when we brave enough to take my two
fellas by default yeah but Obama you
know check out Oh Boehner I bet you as a
really high rating all I'm saying let me
open up Charles Manson's Mia let's see
Obama Barack yeah yeah you know he's a
he's got a four point eight Wow good
look at this feet yeah yeah you like
that dude okay mama come on oh yeah I
did he's done killer he's got some
killer feed pal oh yeah look at that you
got that she's a shot of his feet
there's nothing else in there it's
awesome well you guys give me a minute
I've seen those pictures of him like
paddle surfing like just all just all
ideology and politics aside like the
contrast between like just the [ __ ]
blob of a human being that we have scuse
me we're not getting political whoa I
just got bitched out you can't say that
about our dear leader physicality did
you guys hear this fart that Ethan just
did oh I thought that was a drop was
that really loud it was loud it was loud
it was loud enough that I thought it was
Zach doing a drop yeah it was like Wendy
well Wendy I just got so excited
so we've got Harvey Weinstein we've got
Charles Manson
we've got louis c.k let's see what his
feet have for louis they follow yeah I'm
not trying to put him in the leagues of
such but he doesn't fortunately have a
one point four rating and you can only
see those you can't see anything so do
you think this is an unfair rating for
Louis we need more data
yeah yeah more data required Bill Cosby
has a wiki feed page and Bill Cosby
actually has a nice set of feet photos
and despite his crimes he has a three so
let's have a look I mean these are some
really good chief pics man look at that
you don't there's a lot of foot pics of
you boy look at that one
they so crunched together it's probably
let's bring him down to score a little
yeah yeah that's not a good look here
wrinkled yeah well Bill's on here
Vladimir Putin has a wiki feed page all
right
and you'll be surprised to know he has a
lot o cuz he does martial arts and and
frankly a pretty good rating 3.6 hmm
tons of Vladimir Putin pics and I have
to tell you he's got kind of small feet
what does it say well he's just he's
supposed to be this man in a shoe size 9
he's not really because in Russia
they're all about like hyper masculinity
and he's a short dude with little feet
but he bought he's does karate you know
he rides around on horseback without a
shirt on hmm he makes up for it in other
ways I mean yeah the dude the dude shows
his feet off mana actually you know what
his feet look pretty masculine here I
think I've jerk off on those feet give
me the opportunity right Dan sure
Pol Pot I definitely even thought to
look at the Pol Pot the notorious mass
murder a wiki feed page one star but
here they are nonetheless whole pot
there he has killed millions and he has
a wiki feed page man somebody can you
met I mean to say it's amazing Pol Pot
as a wiki feed page incredible oh
there's comments too who thought this
was a good idea
he killed two million Cambodians but
feet 5 stars I actually looked up
Stalin's he's not on here man that's
incredible so Chet it's a full pot guess
who else is on here Ted Bundy that's
right
notorious serial killer Ted Bundy oh and
they are hideous
the dude did not man oh yeah yeah this
guy's give me the creeps let's get off
Ted Bundy but he's on here one star
ladies and gentlemen Wow I'm feeling
pretty flattered with my rating so far
yeah well Alex Jones is on here coming
out 1.6 and he only has one photo here
look at them
I love his body type Alex gums body type
is epic there's some breaking news about
Alex Jones do you see that no it looks
like a pillowcase over stuff like a over
self pillowcase go ahead what's the
breaking news oh you was arrested for
DUI last night oh you know what I'm so
not surprised DUI what a [ __ ] douche
bag I hate that that that's so shitty I
wonder how drunk was he I don't know any
details I just saw the headline this
morning our Jones arrested for DUI Oh
what is this
Kristen Perez look at this one you know
I have to switch the wiki feat women
yeah
like that's alavés still image you got
it man what has been diesel thing wrote
this yeah I agree I agree what oh yeah
she's got one star dang well VIN Vin
Diesel if he rated this I think he would
he would probably give it a you know she
it's an image Vin Diesel she can't talk
yeah thank you okay
that's what key feet so Pol Pot is on
here Wow is my favorite Charles Manson
is on here Oh Jared Fogle is on here
ladies and gentlemen Jared Fogle of
Subway from an advert apparently of some
sort Jared Fogle yes the affected cereal
agent Marion subway and they cut all the
frames so what do you say about those
feet huh Jared Fogle ladies and
gentlemen once one point two there was
someone who was like you know what for
they're not that bad I can't lie here
Fogle and of course Michael Jackson who
was that very handsome young man he was
[ __ ] he was so fit look at that that's a
twink of I've ever seen one of my life
that's like the definition of a twink
it's such a shame he was a so closeted
gay he could have been like such it he
could have crushed in the gay community
do you know what I mean yo Oh everything
is if only he would have embraced the
fact that he was just a beautiful twink
he would have had so much great gay sex
look at those ABS I'm he was such an
incredible athlete the dancing it was a
very good looking before all the
surgeries yeah very handsome guys oh I
would jerk off onto his feet everything
is a shame about how he was thinking of
himself thoughts on his feet though
mmm-hmm pretty gnarly what's his rate
three low rating for Michael he's all
over the board yeah look at that
yeah poor Michael oh wow
he's got some crazy feet man Michael
Jackson mm-hmm breasts and feet uh-huh
well that's it I'm on on wiki feet I
hope you learned something I hope you
had a couple of laughs I'm sure that a
certain percent of you have your dick
out an r-group man if you didn't drink
off during the segment your own looking
for you right now promise me that if you
do go - boy keep eating jerk off that
you'll come back and finish the episode
at the very least I would like some
emails to let us know if there's anyone
who's listening who is a member of wiki
fit let us know what is the purpose of
the website for you yeah you can write
an anonymously podcast
hjs reproductions calm don't identify
yourself please
well with that being said we are at the
bottom of our show and you know what
time it is
it is time for Dan to send the news
that's right mega doodoo I'm sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
how come your desktop is so much more
vibrant than my yeah oh because I have a
Mac that's the colors are just better
it's like way more vibrant what can I
say you pay you pay a premium for those
colors so um welcome to the news
everyone it's good to be back thank you
I'm lead story today not really lead
story that's not really put in any
particular order you guys saw it right
mm-hmm
the first one either both of them yes
not the first one yes okay so what do
you think I mean you know the actor that
played penny wise bill bill skarsgård
mm-hmm
you did a pretty good job in that role
right yes and you know I think to a lot
of people Tim Curry is the iconic clown
from it mm-hmm but to the younger
generation it's it's gonna be bill and
I'm happy to report that he's gonna be
reprising the role in another movie mmm
it's coming back as penny wise once
again it's not a Stephen King movie
though he's going to be in Space Jam too
Jim still yep is that official uh it's
not completely official but but there
are substantiate ADRA's laying the clown
and patent and yes invasion Space Jam 2
starring LeBron James in the that's
stranger than Pol Pot having a wiki yeah
it's pretty strange and he will be
joining some other characters which it
seems I don't know what this movie is
gonna be I guess the other rumor is that
Jim Carrey will be in it as the mask oh
my god he'll be vicious
well yeah um this movie has had a lot of
problems it was in development hell
forever I think that they fired the
director a few times
I think it's been delayed multiple times
probably going to be a design I think
they need good I think it's time
just yeah abort on yeah well I'm looking
forward to that were you a fan of Space
Jam the original movie you liked it oh
you have like a Space Jam shirt I've
seen you wear at one point right I made
a Space Jam drawing I loved it at the
time I I have not seen the movie you
have not never seen Space Jam
I almost hate to admit it but here at
this iconic r.kelly a great Oh straight
onto your foot oh
Kelly did it I believe I can fly right
oh is it yes all right
good I didn't I thought it was so
amazing that they brought like cartoon
and real people at the same time yeah
and I loved the Looney Tunes yeah yeah a
lot growing up so you know I had all
that going for it in retrospect not a
good movie really awful Michael Jordan
can't act oh and actually good at all
but as a kid it was quite fun all right
Oh continuing on in entertainment news
you guys are familiar with Dolly Parton
of course right it's all apart and don't
Lee pardon she's a big I think so yes
you really you're not that familiar with
her iconic country music yeah oh yeah so
she very famously many many years ago
was the cover girl to Playboy it looks
like he knew it 1978 to but I know you
don't think so we thought you know Zach
knows of course that knows Zach was she
nude in this uh I don't know how you
gonna be on the cover of Playboy why not
show them titties she's got as she must
have yeah well because the cover is
different than the centerfold right I
mean well men are full of I'm correct no
she's not just there's other nudes other
than the centerfold well not anymore
apparently
yeah I know or the story is is that
apparently playboy is now woke
they stopped showing news I do not
realize but I heard that they brought it
back because nobody was buying it really
I don't know though I'm not I'm not well
if they brought it back we're in for
something because apparently she's
looking to get back onto the cover she
had fries the roll ollie is 75 years old
now um what a little I guarantee you
she's on wiki feed do you want to no no
my pardon wiki feet we're finding out no
yeah well she's got a 4.3 I have that's
about what I have you and Dolly let me
see that one with the let me see four
zero zero seven zero four nine four that
one yeah her feet smashed in there whoa
going the wrong direction yes not good
that's the shoe my own
regardless don't wear it doesn't look
comfortable at all what is a Vin Diesel
think about about dog yeah yeah of
course he does he's a little bit more
dog we're finding out today yeah he
likes he likes feet what do you think
about Vin Diesel's feet hmm he's got to
be on wiki feet right yeah yeah sure
we've got a he's got four point three
well let's have a look instead let's
take a look here four point three yeah
I've got I mean not bad he's got about
the same rating with me yeah hello veiny
does that factor in you think I think
people like think we're into the van I
would guess that yeah okay in the case
of guys okay so what else do we have in
the news Dan so finally to round out
Entertainment News this one is kind of
close to home I'm sure you guys have
heard and we were all getting like a
bunch of messages about it - oh our
friend post Malone has been getting
accused of I guess not accused us in the
right word um there's been an outpouring
of concern that
he has been abusing drugs based off of
his performances at concerts which fun
oh yeah yeah bro Crockett this is Philip
DeFranco defranco's Webb sorry sorry
really why don't you personally care
just a lot going on yeah I've obviously
been seeing a lot of this yeah so people
been posting these kind of pictures
right videos of him so yeah let's let's
have a look yeah but there's music I
think good good Zack he's picking up the
mic lovingly I mean you can't really say
he's just not doing it back yeah in this
case I mean he looks a little loopy but
losing out when people are posting this
is the water Z I don't think we should
play the music oh yeah good so he's
singing his eyes are rolling back but
then again he knows the cameras there
he's performing directly to it for the
eye mag you know for the big screen
and yes what's now happened is going
crazy crazy people start emailing you
I'm a sick dude right trust me he's so
his his dad kind of got out there and
said he's tired of this and posted a
video and this is kind of as soon as I
started seeing it it was kind of what I
suspect it was like where videos from
because of cotton you know it's a
concert he plays for an hour where's
where's the rest of it and again Zack I
guess make sure this is muted but you
know here's the same show
same show well as some of them you know
and he's playing he's playing guitar
he's singing definitely that looks like
a sober man to me right exactly and then
he he actually directly addressed it at
one of his concert to get worried for a
minute when because I got so many
messages about it when there's just that
inundation yeah and everyone was
freaking out but then when I saw his
dad's streets there's that one that you
didn't show that was making the rounds
where he was falling on the stage I
don't know if that one's on there
you felt like well when I saw that when
I was like dude he's obviously just
acting not this right
the one where he it's not in this oh how
did road rocket dropped the ball on this
one
but anyway he falls on the stage and
he's singing I fall apart right house
activities obviously just doing
theatrics Denny's and I think most of
these videos where he had his eyes
rolling stuff were from rock star where
I mean it's literally a song about doing
pills and stuff like a rock star so that
seems to be the case at least that's
what he's saying is that he's fine he's
serious I haven't heard there's his yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
but I mean he seems pretty coherent yeah
saying all that he's not slurring at all
he seems pretty with it so yeah I think
I mean I can understand why people get
worried I'll say this about him I don't
talk to him I haven't talked to him in a
while
hmm and his life's just so crazy I don't
think he's on drugs in this moment but I
can you know the guys he has a crazy
life so I mean I hope he stays
responsible and stays healthy I hope so
too what I mean there's certain you're
one of the biggest artists in the world
you're what 23 years a young man you've
got lots of pressures he's always on the
road I hope that but he has you know
what I always thought he was good people
around him like his brother is always
with them who's like so seems like he's
okay yet but you know everybody that was
concerned in but I do because I do uh
you know I do hope that I I don't have
any concerns about him I don't know what
I'm getting at well good right ela
people freaked out well yeah it was
crazy with Twitter like and just a
couple people probably started it and
then it became this whole thing it's a
creative that's thing that's the insane
that's like the stand the stand tality
can I coined that term sanity I kind of
liked it again I mean you know there
have been a spate of big rappers that
have died well that's overdoses in the
last couple years so that's obviously
why people get concise why I express it
in CERN because yeah he's way bigger
than all of them he's got a ton of
pressure he's always on tour he's always
[ __ ] moving
I haven't spoke to him in a while so I
can't speak any I can't speak from any
empirical place but I just he doesn't
live in Los Angeles anymore right no
right now you know yeah obviously that
makes it tougher well good I'm glad uh
he but in the time that I've known him
he was he was never abused drugs ever
no he only ever drank beer you never
touched anything else haven't ever
anything else
just for the record I'll say that and
I'm just he's never ever touched
anything else then when I've been with
them mmm go good to know dan is there
anything else yeah this past Sunday was
International Women's Day congratulation
gradually low thank you
they're men's day I think some people
would argue most days are men's day
would argue that I don't know point them
out to me but uh what do I get for women
well what I'll tell you what you get you
get something I mean you may get a few
things but one set of people that are
gonna be taking care of you is the Shell
Oil Company because to commemorate
International Women's Day they
temporarily changed their name from
shell to Michelle - she'll - she will
know how awesome doesn't mine oil and
shut up how cool is that why there you
go this is who you ELA Hey hail
empowered you pump your gas just from
there she'll wow I want to blow up a gas
station make the future gender balance
throw your at Gao station shut the [ __ ]
up
oh my god about you so don't see it go
go build a I go build a couple of solar
panels or something talk about shell
yeah I would do a lot more good for the
world than Allah what do you think
you're thinking no one would ever care
about this who cares
well that is they actually spend money
like we went through all this trouble to
do this
three you bring the stuff and put it on
you know whenever I see something like
this I always just always think of the
meetings in the marketing and all the
money spent the time thought and then
they have to print all these shells to
put over and then they have to take it
off I mean wow that's a lot of effort
for very little right now it's a it
they're all know you missed your
opportunity on Sunday they already put
him and took him all off it's not
International Women's Day we why would
they but that's probably not everywhere
to know in fact I think it was very
limited this one was in San Dimas though
which is uh not far from here so we we
could have gone show look I may not have
to remember but shall shale oil did so
congratulations again you did it and
speaking of oil the biggest point drop
in the history of the stock market
happened yesterday
what about time people seen this I guess
would be two days ago Monday let's just
say Monday mm-hmm and the biggest
one-day loss in percentage-wise since
2008 October 2008 which I can't really
remember what was going on in October
2000 that was the housing crisis oh
that's right yeah oh when the economy
collapse yeah that was a good one yeah
that's so but I will say so when they
say that it's important to remember that
the point system doesn't it's not
comparable because there's and used to
be expressed per percentage cuz the
points are higher right that's what I
was saying the persona the percentage is
higher well the it's the the biggest
percent drop Oh since October 2008 Wow
how I guess actual point drop ever I see
so yeah probably basic deal it was based
on Corona and also there was some issue
with oils that right yeah so I guess
there is a price war going on between
and we also apply pact between Saudi
Arabia and Russia collapsed and both
countries vowed high-production are too
close to Sal eyes right and so oh sure
yeah I really wanted to talk about this
though in all of these articles about
the stock market there's all these
photos of like looking frazzled what did
you get these I know Getty Images yeah
what what does Vin Diesel think about
this phone yeah any tell me yeah tell me
he's like an old Wolverine he's got like
a Wolverine hair can you tell me how is
the market done today did it rebound uh
so this morning it was fluctuating
wildly it was up overnight and then it
dropped lost all of that but then later
this afternoon it looked like it was
back up and at the moment it's back up
significantly a thousand points wait
what yeah well again and does this
affect any of us in any way at all uh
well I mean obviously if you have a 401k
if you have retirement in stock market
it affects you have old brains they'll
be dying and they'll be perishing eyes
this virus spreads anyway there's
certainly that what happens to their
money when they all perish the wait do
we get it you talking about just old
people in general that I mean like think
about Corona wipes out all the old
people trickle down we're good for the
economy old trickle-down economics yeah
Social Security all their money trickles
down to us my friend they didn't have
much money no they do they've got 401ks
they hoard it those old [ __ ] they
hoard it that's a good question it if I
had to guess it probably what I'm trying
to say is buy because if this virus
comes and wipes decimates every old
person trickle down less security okay
it's gonna help the economy I think the
main thing aside from the oil stuff is
the supply chain disruptions which I I'm
sure you guys are intimately familiar
with for us all kinds of stuff through
fresh and everything and everybody's
feeling it right now so yeah we're going
in yeah I think I think everything will
be for a while now so we'll see what
happens we'll see how that develops but
well I wish the best to this uh this
dude on the on the Oracle here I wish
him well
oh I hope he's having a better day today
I thought you somebody was having a
better day he had hair at the beginning
of the day this guy is 20 my right old
am i right nice big news in the world of
World Records mmm love World Records on
the show yes we do the largest gathering
of Smurfs everett's 3,500 people they
they braved hold and everything I just I
was reading the headline and I just
struck by Lices says around 3500 Smurfs
set aside their fears of Verona
what now did you uh have the Smurfs show
yeah they're with it actually you liked
it yeah now I wondered if they had it in
Israel because kind of famously I don't
know if you've guy yeah that's America
conspiracy theory I think we spoke he's
an evil wizard implication no I don't
think Gargamel is a Jewish name however
his cat his little cat is named Azrael
that's a Jewish name oh yeah Angel of
Death God but I can see that does have a
big nose magic powers he loves gold Hey
kind of looks jewy in general do we know
anything about the creator was he and
Nazi was he in hell with this show all
right
I believe it's Belgian originally which
does that mean for us but the Smurfs are
the good guys and he's the bad guy
yeah oh wait wait wait yes that's not
good well for the if you're buying into
this idea that based on a Jewish integer
so what is sold if we flush out the
analogy the Smurfs are I don't care to
follow it that much to be fun
identify personally with Gilgamesh you
feel you feel Gilgamesh wants to get rid
of these Smurfs we're honestly I just
want a solution of this Smurf problem
you could say a final solution yeah I
would say that it's a very big show in
Israel or it was yeah yeah I always
hated it as a kid me tell really I
didn't really wasn't it too dumb never
capture my imagination
here's here's something that did capture
my imagination in Colorado they they
know how to handle politics they have
elected you have to ban is turning
Parker the snow dog sworn in as the
mayor of Georgetown Colorado just take a
look that is so epic you know it's funny
he will probably govern better than most
I loved elected officials he rules look
at this guy yeah his own Instagram I'm
now a follower of yeah he looks official
looks big
he is official he is literally an
official of so I'm assuming a lot of
smaller towns the he's been at Auburn
he's gonna sign bail he's been a feat of
yeah he's gonna set budget hmm that's a
good question about nobody possible
corruption the snow dog yeah and but you
know has a good point what
this actually mean that this dog is an
elected official I my in tells me the
mayor doesn't hold a lot of executive
power in this particular town well if it
may be more of like a figurehead of
sorts I think in a lot of small towns
the mayor doesn't really do it's just a
member of the community
exactly yeah it's just more of a
figurehead like show up for a parade
right saying all right and so he can
fulfill that value the best way possible
exactly if he's not doing a good job
Garcetti concepting daddy
Garcetti from your daddy and I forget YZ
all right what else we got there all
right I got a few more this is the only
I know this has gone on for a while so
this is the only important one there's a
in Australia there's this famous artist
who very controversial II because I
believe some governmental grants were
given for that to help create this thing
made this giant balloon called a sky the
sky whale and it had been gone for a few
years but it's back take a look at this
thing let me know what you think of this
looks like nipples yeah
sky whale returns looks like a bunch of
nips oh they're supposed to be legs I
think they're actually are supposed to
be nipples
apparently it [ __ ] freakiest thing
[Laughter]
look out your window and seeing this fly
it's for all your listeners there's a
giant whale head and then like ten
humanoid kind of like a cow like utters
almost those look like female titties
yeah it's uh apparently can fly it's a
hot air balloon
this thing flies mmm what is that Vin
Diesel think about it
yeah it's true right I guess some people
just want a lot of nipples right this
looks like when you try to bake and it
just completely goes wrong
so yeah I'm I couldn't find a video of
it flying around because I think they're
still just testing it I don't think that
thing I ever took off to play I don't
know man and finally I just wanted to
share this story you know things are
we're in a political season things get
very heated but just as a reminder of
how much worse it could be there was
just elections in Afghanistan and I
guess the results unfortunately are
contended and now you have a situation
where people are just acting like
they're depress it had more so I mean
one the Electoral Commission says the
incumbent Ashraf Ghani narrowly won but
was his name Ashraf Ghani my very
positive thing that and the other guy's
name if the guy's name is Abdullah
Abdullah say it again Abdullah Abdullah
what's his last name
Abdullah it's pretty common and his
first name Abdullah does he have a
middle name I don't know I guess what's
his middle name this is a good chance so
say all three of his names Abdullah
Abdullah ah God I'm pretty common for
why is that common why have they not
figured out to change the name why do
you need the same name twice especially
if there's so many people with the same
name isn't the name to distinguish you
from other people it is deep okay it
says a lot about the culture yep think
about it because we value individuality
here hmm but if you over there you have
two names let's say your name's Mohammed
Mohammed everybody's over there names
Mohammed how many people are Mohammed
Mohammed what's the point of having
names and distinguishing yourself from
other people
you're just gonna say oh my name's
Mohammed Mohammed you got a billion
Mohammed Mohammed is running around
there's no individuality going on a rant
okay apparently Daenerys no look
apparently Abdullah only had a first
name and demands from Western newspaper
editors for a family name led him to
adopt the full name Abdullah Abdullah so
it was actually his own choice
what's your name okay well now I want to
know what's his middle name and I demand
it if he didn't have a last now I don't
think they do me yeah yeah but if the
paper can get him to give a second name
then I demand a middle name and I want
him to say it so no no well it's not a
thing
there's a lot about your culture well
what does it first of all there's a lot
less Israelis because in America let's
say that in America there could be like
you know a million
Ethan Klein's that's but there's not
many what the same middle name is me
maybe one or even zero I guess you don't
really use the middle name well if
there's someone with the exact same name
as you it's helpful I don't know what is
your middle name I'm not gonna say it on
air really it's the only thing that's
all you have it's Edward I think it's I
think it's public I got very well no no
it's not embarrassing I go they don't
every we've um we've said it actually
because it's how we came up with a h3h3
right yeah it's we've said it before mmm
Ethan Edward so is there anything else
in the news as we yeah just one last
thing this is less of a story and more I
just I I found this so [ __ ] funny
that just had to share you probably
remember our old friend Representative
Paul goes go sir
bizarre sounds like a yes remember
getting go Zard this was the guy with
the family who made an epic political ad
oh we're all learned on yes we said with
that we call it getting go stars and go
Zard okay so yeah mr. Kozar I won't talk
in specific he get goes are did well he
got something he may
may or may not be in quarantine right
now from oh no he got goes RT no sorry
and then he tweeted this been thinking
about life in mortality today
I'd rather die gloriously in battle than
from a virus in a way it doesn't matter
but it kind of does I saw this tweet and
he did it along with a picture of what
appears to be an ancient Chinese all
rattle right you know I saw this tweet
and I didn't realize it was gozar but
now I understand why his entire family
and something else I noticed about this
is his tag is dr. Paul Gosar he's not a
doctor well so I was curious I looked it
up and he's not a medical doctor he's a
dentist how do you feel about dentists
did you have a degree well I believe you
do need a type of doctorate to become a
dentist so it's fine it's I'm tied then
tie if you have a doctor's degree it's
like a little bit of doctor Envy right
like I meant don't I that's a Seinfeld
thing well if you say is anyone here a
doctor and then the dentist gets up it's
like don't yell not you right no but a
doctor is a it's a title I know I know I
know
yeah I think he deserves doctor do you
think it's helmet how many years of
school do you go to for the dentistry me
it's the same amount hey that's a good
question not years - yeah my instincts
isn't it well let's see and then we in
decide does he have a doctorates I mean
that's really the question four years
four years to become a doctor is like
eight wait hold on hold on
you know what you must there must be
some further dentistry school you can do
optionally maybe just say sorry you can
they had a doctor in four years Google
this our dentists do dentistry at
degrees yeah right their doctorates
a DDS and in DMD degrees are considered
equivalent the majority of dental scores
award the DDS however some award the D
MD I'm assuming the MD is the is the me
MD is doctor right then there's some
broke-ass for his Doctor of Dental
Surgery and Doctor of Dental Medicine so
he can prescribe medicine everything
that's a dog if you can prescribe
medicine your dog okay fair enough I
won't take that away from him but but in
talking about that glorious that time I
was gonna say that being said his whole
family did make a hate piece against
them anyone by the way yeah he did when
he's in Congress he as a representative
how do you win when your whole family
makes the head piece again like listen
nobody knows this guy better than Oscar
his whole family do not vote for him any
still a little crazy and and that's it
for the news today well thank you for
the news and thank you Dan thank you
thank you thank you Friday
Tricia's coming in oh yeah it's gonna be
great so do not go stay at your computer
until then alright thanks for watching
everybody
thanks for watching
you
[Music]